you're you know you have three children
and most recently Margaret uh Kali who
is such a renowned and respected actress
she's good isn't she and incredible
dancer oh I watch I stare at her all the
time what was it like to cuz now I have
two daughters yeah I was just asking
about your kids yes and Frankie said to
me on the street the other day well
she's like well I'm going to be an
actress you know when I grow up and I
said okay I will support you and help
you in any way I can they know I won't
let them now I'm like you have to be
kids and the same thing yeah mhm oh so
I'm I'm doing it right I think so I do
because well you were a child actress I
remember oh my gosh the first time I saw
you I just forgot about that you came to
a party you were a child yep you came to
the S Elmo's Fire party I sure did what
were you doing there and how
how old were you probably like oh God
what year did St ELO's Fire come out I
don't know I can't think right now I
don't know I don't no we'll see um I was
maybe 25 or 26 I don't I don't I don't
know Drew but you were young I was 10 oh
my 1985 what were you doing there I just
remember and I remember thinking that
Kirby emelo AZ like literally was my
first slow dance at the Lassa club for
Rob blow's birthday party and that's the
guy who's in love with you in st's fire
yeah yeah well I don't know I don't know
about you but I worked with kids and I
just it's really a job it's a job I just
wanted them to have whatever a normal
life is it's like I don't know what is a
normal life in the end but I don't know
everything you're saying is making me
feel so validated for my choices I'm so
glad it is a job it's a job I do agree
it's like not for kids and it's not for
kids but they could do school plays yeah
that's why I said theater and then when
you're ready school play and do it
really like on School level plays D you
got to do maid with Margaret that's this
critically acclaimed Bel love Netflix on
sort of episodic film I got that job
because of her she she suggested me what
was it like to act with your daughter
knowing okay we protected them we raised
them to the best of our ability I'm
still in it you're there and now you're
and look at the character I had to play
but I felt very you know we we felt
really safe with each other and um I
just had a hard time watching her work
so hard she worked so hard the hours
were excruciating for her she she had
ter a terrible schedule so that was hard
I would cook for her on the weekend I
would make soup for her and this and get
her a massage and try to hold her
together a little bit and then she would
be off do you see what I'm saying do you
see and
feel